sorry now I'm getting emotional um
Malcolm Gladwell
business Guru a rock star journalist I
just want to explain things to people
it's not in your best interests to work
at home if you're just sitting in your
pajamas in your bedroom is that the work
life you want to live we want you to
have a feeling of belonging and to feel
necessary and if you're not here it's
really hard to do that what if you
reduced your life to
the language of happiness has to go
alongside the this question of what
contribution you're making to the world
you live in if you could make an amazing
contribution to society as you have at
the cost of your unhappiness would you
choose that
no wow
we're social animals casting someone out
is the great sin it is not conflict that
drives people away it is neglect that's
when you do harm
sorry now I'm getting emotional um
it's varied I don't know sorry
[Music]
if we don't feel like we're part of
something important what's the point
[Music]
so without further Ado I'm Stephen
Bartlett and this is the Diary of a CEO
I hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
um first of all I want to say thank you
I feel obliged to you because your books
outliers blink have been very formative
for me as over the last 10 years since I
was running my businesses and trying to
understand certain dynamics that I
didn't understand those books seem to
arrive in my life at the right time so
it's a real honor to to get to speak to
you today oh thank you
um going back then what are the what you
know you've become a
tremendously well known and highly
acclaimed writer and thinker and
podcaster but when I think back to your
your early years says before 10 years
old what were the factors that you look
back now in hindsight and connect and
say Ah that's the reason I ended up
becoming the person I am today
oh wow you you mean you say before the
age of 10 yeah like sub 10. well I by at
the age of 10 I had been I had already
lived in three countries wow Jamaica
maybe even four well Jamaica England and
Canada
and it's possible a brief stint in the
United States so I was well traveled
um although you know you're dimly aware
of these things at that age
um and I had a uh you know I have an
English father and a had an English
father and a Jamaican mother so I was
conscious of myself as an outsider
a little bit which I think is very
useful
um
and
I was living in that point in
kind of Southwestern Ontario
the kind of one of the
sleepiest but also most amazing
places in
the West I mean a
a place of kind of uh almost absurdly
happy people and no crime or dysfunction
and you know 10 churches in every
village and
uh a kind of I realize now in retrospect
a kind of magical place to have to I
grew up without any kind of broader
anxieties
so there was I was never scared of
anything there was nothing to be scared
of when I was when I was growing up um
which I realized now was probably an
enormous blessing
on that first point of realizing that
you're a bit of an outsider why'd you
cite that as being a a good thing
for a lot of people that leads to
bullying and feeling you know feelings
of sort of social inadequacy but why'd
you say that's a good thing well I think
of it as liberating
you know I'll give you a small example
when I first came to Canada I was six
years old and in in rural Canada when
you're six all the boys have been
playing ice hockey since they were in
skating since they were four
so I remember very distinctly
being aware of the fact that everyone
played hockey and I didn't and also
being aware of the fact that wrongly but
I felt that it was too late for me to
learn so I was permanently outside of
hockey culture I was the only boy who
didn't play which is incredibly
liberating which meant that I could
choose none of them got to choose what
they
wanted to do right I did you know it so
it was like I didn't have to participate
in
these kind of uh compulsory rituals of
the Canadian upbringing
um and having choices
being an outsider it does allow you
a kind of range of Freedom that is
denied people who are embedded in a
culture
and what did you choose
well eventually running
um but I think I chose just to you know
the amount of time
seven-year-olds spend playing hockey in
Canada is enormous I mean it's just so I
think I just had more time to read and
kind of it said full-time job for for an
eight-year-old or a seven-year-old
um you know I just I I had a quite a
solitary childhood which again I think
was a blessing
um
you know I think a lot of I didn't I
didn't I had time to kind of indulge my
curiosity and read lots of books and
um I wasn't kind of I see a lot of
children today pushed into unwanted
social interaction I don't understand
what is it really necessary if you're if
you're seven you'd rather spend an
evening by yourself
isn't that fine I think it should be
fine one of the things that I you know I
read about in uh the story of success
was about the impact that parental
involvement at that young age and this
is kind of maybe maybe somewhat linked
to what we're talking about parental
involvement can have on someone's
outcomes and I my parents were I was the
youngest child of four so my parents had
resigned to the fact that they had to
parent me so I had this huge freedom and
I think I always cite that as being the
reason I went on to become an
entrepreneur because I had this huge
void of Independence
but um so I wanted to get your take on
on that because I that led me to believe
that
less parental involvement would lead to
Greater Independence which would lead to
better outcomes yeah but except that yes
I actually completely agree with you but
I wonder whether
um you know the kind of so if you're
describing a kind of benign neglect
which is which youngest children I'm
also a youngest often encounter but
benign neglect is not the same as a lack
of Parental involvement because it's
it's benign neglect it's also it's
considered neglect it's that your
parents have simply they haven't removed
a safe structure around you the
structure remains in place what they've
removed they just stopped hovering over
you they realize it's no longer
necessary or productive or they no
longer have the time for it but they've
not abandoned you
so you know I think it's you know
sometimes I think we those of us who are
youngest
um do our parents a little bit of a
disservice when we when we when we
describe their absence from our
childhood They're Not absent they're
um they're just simply wiser in a way
that they that they uh that they they
choose to parent yeah I thought my
parents were absent but you're right
the house was still hot we had a reef
over our head I was still attending
school yeah I got expelled ultimately
for like 30 attendance but I was still
kind of going you know I did the same
thing yeah I read about that I thought
yeah we were similar but my mother was
complicit in my my mother would was
quite happy if I chose to die oh really
well I think she realized my mother is
quite subversive in a very very quiet
West Indian kind of way and I think she
understood that
if she chose to
I didn't have any great desire to go to
go to school on a regular basis I think
she realized that if she
opposed that desire should make it worse
so she decided instead to endorse it and
so it kind of she sort of diffused
whatever rebellious
intent I had
just by saying she would sign fake notes
for me to give to the principal I mean
she was wow
wow
what about your father what was he like
he said you were very very competitive
he thought I think he was competitive I
don't know whether I think I was quite
competitive but in a kind of at games
and at running
um my father was a a very very
Englishman he was
from Kent he was uh he liked dogs and
gardening
and long walks in the rain
uh he was
uh exceedingly intelligent but it
combined with a kind of humility that
was
and I realized that as I get older it's
the humility that was the more important
um aspect of his
uh personality so he would never he was
probably smarter than most people he met
but he would never ever
Make That explicit and he was if he
thought that you even had a slight edge
of knowledge in some domain over him he
would defer to you
which made him an incredibly curious
he was curious about everything and
would ask
he had friendships with people who had
dropped out of school at the age of 10.
I mean he was and he was a man with a
PhD in
you know in mathematics
um so he was a wonderful he was he was a
really wonderful role model for a uh for
a little boy
how did you and why and how did you
learn the value of that humility and the
impact and the importance of it when
you're dealing with other people
well I think it's because
you can't be a good journalist unless
you have
a kind of uh Baseline respect for what
others can teach you if you're going to
interview be a good interviewer you must
enter into every interview
with the expectation that you know less
that the person you're interviewing has
someone something to tell you
right and that's actually much more
difficult than it sounds because nor in
normal conversation we have an urge to
assert ourselves and we think we have a
kind of
um intellectual Advantage informational
advantage that's why we you watch people
talk
interruptions are all about often about
the other person asserting
their superiority on that point someone
says oh it'll take me forever to get
here the other person says no it won't
right
you can't be a journalist if you have to
turn that off if you want to Be an
Effective interviewer you have to trust
that
this person ultimately can teach me
something that I can't learn on my own
even if in the moment I'm not getting
anywhere you just have to quiet that
voice and let them
keep going and keep
you know asking the right kind of
questions that requires an assertion of
humility
um it took me years to Kind of Perfect
that as a journalist
um and I would watch it when I worked at
the Washington Post
I would watch the great journalists and
they all had that just that ability to
kind of
to to make it plain to whoever they were
talking to I know less than you that's
why I'm having this that's why we're
having this conversation right
it's a beautiful thing when it's done
right when it's done well
it's gonna be reflecting on various
people one of the people that made me
reflect on the interesting he was Joe
Rogan
how he's he feels like such a bridge to
his audience listeners because he does
come across as being tremendously humble
regardless of who's who he's speaking to
he always seems to understand his
intelligence as well
who always calls himself a monkey yes
that's a kind of yeah yeah well he yes
he well he has this wonderful thing
um where he can put himself
he's squarely in the position of his
listeners which is a really you know for
a for a host of
of any kind of show like that is if you
can do that you can win you're going to
win right he there's there's he's he's
having the conversation that his
listeners wish they could be having with
with these subjects in his in his uh on
his show
on that point of Journalism at what
point in your your early years did you
was there any inclination that you might
become a journalist you might go into
that profession if any
never in the I mean I had thought about
I liked writing I didn't imagine that it
was a
profession it didn't occur to me that
you could actually make a living doing
it so I always was thinking of other
things I wanted to do and then I kind of
fell into it by accident after my after
I I graduated from uh University so I I
never really I just I thought something
you did on the side you know I I didn't
it seemed unimaginable that somebody
would pay you to do
this kind of work lack of Role Models
lack of
I mean I think it's a it's a little bit
of a if I grown up in
you know New York or
Toronto or London
I would have been much more aware of
people who who
you know were in the creative
professions but I grew up in a town of 4
000 people there were no one there was
no one in my town who made a living in
the creative professions right you you
wouldn't live in a small town like that
and do that so I didn't know I have
friends who grew up in you know
Manhattan and they they knew they knew
film my film filmmakers and actors and
you know fiction writers and is as part
of their parents Circle when they're
growing up I knew none of that what
advice would you give to to people
around that age say that you know early
20s just maybe just graduated and
thinking about going off into the world
because I hear a lot of these these
stories about certain small factors can
have such a tremendous impact on your
outcomes like the city you live in would
you encourage you younger people to go
and get into those big cities if they're
if they're trying to
have careers in things like journalism
or Media or whatever or business and how
much of a how much of a swing does that
have because I always think you know I'm
on Dragonstone and I see these
entrepreneurs coming in and pitching
tech companies and I always think
sometimes I think you're at like a 90
disadvantage versus just being over
there on the west coast of America in
San Francisco
um I I think sometimes I think it's more
than a 90 disadvantage but situational
and environmental factors on outcomes
it's always been this puzzle
in many countries but particularly
United States about why do immigrants do
so well
and
uh you know the one of the explanations
was immigrants to the United States have
always been very aggressive about
seeking educational opportunities or
maybe they brought with them education
that so that was one argument for the
longest time but now we realize actually
it's less that and more that they unlike
many people many Native Americans are
willing to move where opportunities are
so the the
immigrants are mobile
in a way they don't have any Roots they
don't have family that's keeping them in
one place another they simply make a
beeline for the
places where they can you know further
their own economic and personal
interests the quickest and the most
efficiently native
people don't do that too many
encumbrances
my advice to people young people is
always where do you want to move
first question you should ask yourself
your your default should be you're going
to move somewhere
right don't fall in the Trap of doing
when you're 23 of doing the comfortable
thing and staying near family and
friends that's there'll be plenty of
time for that later
only question on your mind should be
where should I move and once you decide
where you move I think a lot of other
things fall into place so if you are
someone who
imagines it you would like to start a
company in the tech world and then yeah
move to move to Northern California or
Austin Texas or Tel Aviv or whatever you
know go where the I think you're
absolutely right you need to go where
the opportunity is it's not going to
come to you magically and you are at a
huge disadvantage if you're not there
it's it's just no question about that
people have confused the efficiency of
digital communication the kind of um the
logistical efficiency of digital
communication with emotional efficiency
and kind of psychological efficiency it
is it is only logistically efficient it
does not resolve the quiz and help
someone trust you more or take a chance
on you or get to know you in all of your
complexity yes
I wish yeah it's one of the things my
parents said to me at very young age was
we lived in Devon which is you know
Devon right down in the corner on the
farm
um and they they were very clear at
young age they said you've got to leave
here so just just so you're all well
aware for the four of us you have all
got to go out of this city so when we
were all very clear on that and all of
my friends are still there every single
one of them all of my best friends are
still in Plymouth even if they went to
University in another city they came
back
um it's not to say that they're not
happier than me and this is maybe my
next question which is
um because like because I hear that
immigrant tell all the time that
immigrants tend to have better outcomes
relatively whatever it might be but my
question becomes um are they happier and
I say this actually because of a
conversation I was having last night
with my friend who has built his family
have built a billion dollar company in
this country
um the dad was the first generation
immigrant here the dad is just
completely overwhelmed with work like he
is obsessed to the point now the sun
said to me last night I don't actually
think he could he knows what makes him
happier little but because he was in
survival mode when he came here they've
got a billion dollars actually I think
it was worth five billion now but is he
happy
and I I sometimes ponder that the first
sort of generation immigrant is on
survival mode the second generation has
the chance of being in a maybe a
thriving self-actualization
situation but I don't know if you had
any light to shed on first generation
happiness I'm always I'm dubious of this
so I I all this happiness stuff and I
say this and I'm I'm fully open to the
possibility that I'm wrong but
um my understanding of happiness is
because of the research on happiness is
that it's a fairly stable
trait in other words there are people
who are happy
regardless of where they are and people
who are not or people who don't appear
happy or people for whom happiness
represents itself differently so I would
say of your friend's father
you know maybe he is happy he just
expresses it differently he built a
massive business he's made his family
stable he's created a secure beachhead
in a whole new country you don't think
that makes him happy when he puts his
head on the pillow at night I think it
probably does it's just not just it's
not the kind of lie on the beach read a
good book happy but it sounds to me like
a
pretty amazing set of accomplishments
that would make him will he die happy
having done that yes he will I think I
don't know I never met the man but I'm
just I'm wondering generally what's that
people say they've never met a happy
billionaire
I just don't I don't believe that I
think they derive I think people who've
who've um accomplished something like
that they drive a different kind of
satisfaction from it
but it doesn't it's not a lesser kind of
satisfaction
um
you know do I work more than most people
if I look at the cohort of people I went
to college with University with do I
work more than most of them yeah
probably
uh do I spend less time
you know uh watching movies and reading
books and going on holiday yes
absolutely does that mean I'm less happy
no I think I'm pretty happy
I
you know it's like and I I just I yeah
that's I'm a little bit skeptical of
this narrow definition of happiness so
so I think I think it's based on this
idea that to be happy or whatever you
have to have this kind of recipe of
ingredients and they have to be equally
balanced you have to have you know
strong interpersonal relationships or
meaningful connections you have to have
you know exercise you know these kinds
of things so when you see an individual
who's so out of balance because they
they just work 20 you know every waking
out of every day and they don't make
time for friends families or walking the
dog people and they're you know consumed
by it people from the outside go well
that's that's not a happy person and you
would I would think the science would
support the fact that people tend to be
happier when they have stronger more
meaningful relationships and they have
more of more balance in their lives
generally yeah no I think so you
understand I'm making so let's go back
to your friend's father so your friend's
father is uh not someone about whom we
can generalize yeah uh he's clearly a
you know he's an outlier of some
um
sword he's probably he's in I imagine
there's a whole series of traits that
he's in the 99th percentile on probably
incredibly intelligent incredibly driven
you know list them all so that kind of
person is never going to have
a balanced life I mean you could put him
in
you know the the the the the cornfields
of Iowa and say you're going to be a
you're going to be a farmer that's all
you can do and he's gonna he's gonna
live he's gonna be someone who's like
working you know 80 hours a week and
right that's just his temperament so the
question is what I'm saying is happiness
for him is probably going to look
differently than happiness for lots of
other people but he's highly unusual
for the average person yes balance is is
appropriate but you didn't ask me about
an average person you asked me about
someone who's who built built an
enormous business from scratch
yeah I worry I think I worry sometimes
part of the reason I think ask the
questions for myself that I'm being
dragged by my own like insecurity so I
sit here with a lot of you know
successful maybe billionaire CEOs that
have built these great companies and you
find out that the reason they built them
is because their mother
um in the case of one of my previous
guests which was on two weeks ago who
and he said this on the podcast he's got
a billion dollar beer company you find
out because his mother when he was a
young kid basically always convinced him
he was never enough he should come into
his room smash his toys and say things
to him to convince him that he was just
never good enough so he's had this
almost neurotic obsessive drive to prove
to the world that he is good enough and
you wonder how voluntary that that that
drive is and what it's come at the cost
of and is he really
you know is this individual really
happy and fulfilled or are they just
being pulled by their insecurities but
you know there are maybe another way of
saying this is that
um so to use that person as an example
so he took uh uh a kind of trauma and
made something productive out of it yeah
he had a great deal of certain personal
costs but he took something that might
have defeated others and ended up
contributing substantially to society I
wouldn't he may not be happy but I would
describe his life as a Triumph
right and the other thing I would say is
that the language of happiness has to go
alongside the this question of what
contribution you're making to the world
you live in that there are many people
who are not personally happy but who
make enormous contributions and that's
that's a parallel and in many cases far
more important
um function you know was
Florence Nightingale happy probably
probably not Jews she's supposed to tell
from what I know about her life she had
all kinds of psychological issues or
whatever but she made an enormous
contribution that continues to this day
right she started a Hulk you know so
there are like I said I would like to
have a kind of
I would like to the to evaluate people's
lives along a whole series of dimensions
and understand that not everyone can
satisfy each of those dimensions in any
moment one of those
you know being happy feels like
something that I would like for me
making a great contribution to society
feels like something that others would
like from me and I I wonder you know
which if you could make a huge this is
just a tangent here but if you could
make it amazing you know contribution to
society as you have at the cost of your
unhappiness
would you choose that
depends on what the contribution was the
contribution you've made in your life
you've helped millions and millions oh I
see uh
would I have done what I did if I
thought it was coming at a significant
cost to my own happiness yeah uh
probably not but then I think the world
you know but if I was doing if I was a
you know uh a a biologist who had
working on a breakthrough for some
disease I might the calculation might be
different I mean I'm not saving lives
I'm entertaining people or enlightening
them but it didn't read me they would be
enlightened somewhere else I'm not
crucial to the functioning of society
but if I was
I might feel very differently I think
you know it's funny where the I'm I'm
over here because I have this
um book now in paperback the bomber
Mafia and it's a story of these
uh group of men pilots in the 1930s in
America who have a dream about
a better way to fight Wars and they're
all down in Alabama and they have these
ideas about how the bomber
high altitude Precision bombing can
revolutionize Warfare and save countless
civilian lives their dream turns out to
be
uh
they can't pull it off in a second world
war they they start out the war with
high hopes and by the end many of them
have had their careers destroyed because
they pursued an idea which didn't work
it didn't work at the time now it does
work they really pioneered a kind of
warfare that is
um essential to the way we think about
war today and as as today you know saves
countless lives didn't work in their
time frame so in a sense they sacrificed
their career and large part of their
happiness for uh uh for a future cause
they were long dead before it
paid off am I glad they did that
absolutely
would they be glad if you resurrected
some of these guys from the dead and you
said look I know in 1936 you had a
vision about how to make war better and
it was finally realized during the
Kosovo campaign of the 90s 60 years
later
are you happy you did what you did
uh you do feel now that it was worth
sacrificing your entire career over this
lost cause because it turned out not to
be a lost cause and they would I'm sure
from the grave they would say I am so
grateful that I did what I did right
even though one of these guys one of
them one of the heroes of the book is a
man named Haywood Hansel
brilliant passionate
romantic figure in the second world war
who has this extraordinary set of ideas
about how to revolutionize the era war
in the second world war which he tries
and fails to implement in the war
against Japan and by his by the age of
40 he's this is a man who devoted his
life to the Air Force he's a career his
father and grandfather they're all like
career Military Officers he this is his
whole world
he's basically through
by the
by his late 30s he's just pushed out to
pasture and spends the next 30 years of
his life basically
as the guy who failed in the second
world war right
he would say it was worth it I think if
you think so yeah I think he did I think
he would and I'm we should all be
enormously grateful to him for making
that sacrifice
um
I I am grateful for them for making that
sacrifice but I tend to believe that
people are more
motivated by their own
ego than they typically often allow
their own sense of like wanting to
accomplish something so they can be
someone that accomplished something and
I tend to actually think this probably
from doing this podcast so much where I
often get to the root cause of a
successful person's achievements and
find out it was just time and time again
it was just an insecurity from their
childhood
it was they had it you know they were
bullied they were beaten up and it's
this almost involuntary pursuit to prove
the bully my mum uh being outcasted and
being nearly black in an all-white
school to to fit in or to prove someone
wrong and if and then you look at it
from the outside and you clap and go oh
they were courageous or they were Brave
no they were insecure so why wait why
why does it bother you that insecurity
manifests itself as courage and
absolutely doesn't I did a a tour of
this country where I opened the show and
say you call me Brave I was actually
just insecure yeah so it doesn't bother
me I just think it's reality we didn't
talk and I think obviously in hindsight
bias we we say oh this person will say
courageous they were so intentional they
had most of the time they were just
insecure like they didn't get Christmas
presents and they were bad but that
makes I like that though because it to
me to my mind it makes courage far more
accessible when we realize that courage
can have many many fathers I love it
yeah I think it's beautiful it's a
beautiful notion and the idea people can
take what can be harmful damaging
traumatic things like I was saying
before and spin them into gold is this
is the this is the at the heart of what
is so kind of Joyful about you the human
Spirit right it's it's incredible like
that was actually the the headline of
the Guardian newspaper two weeks ago was
my face with the title that said uh
insecurity was my greatest motivator and
it was and it was because I never
understood this idea that I was because
I expelled from school dropped out of
University after one lecture I never
understood this idea that other people
thought I was Brave when and really I
was like a coward running away from
things I didn't like fueled by
insecurities like oh it was actually
cowardice and insecurity if you're
really being honest yeah and so go match
your point about these um
you know these these people from the
1950s yeah 1950s 30s I wonder what there
driving underlying force was because
well they were it's funny so there's a
little group of men and they call
themselves the Brahma Mafia
and they are
they're all in their 20s
they're young men in the 1930s and
they're in the army
and there's no such thing as the Air
Force in the 1930s anywhere and Air
Force is a division of the uh of the
Army in most countries and the people
running armies in the 1930s think planes
are a joke they're a toy right and here
are these young guys and they actually
think planes are what the future of
warfare is and they feel they feel
overlooked and ignored and they're you
know in the 1930s if you were in the
Army you had to spend time you know
learning how to ride a horse because the
Cavalry was still a thing and they would
you know you'd have to
groom your horses and you know Trot
around the and these guys think this is
a joke right they're just this is the
most absurd thing they've ever seen why
are we riding horses when we've invented
this thing called an airplane which can
fly hundreds of miles and drop bombs and
revolutionize Warfare and no one's
listening to them and they they're they
are
um they feel like they're outcasts
who are in an institution that they
don't belong in and they're they're
really at a loss and their solution is
they're all up in Virginia right around
the where military headquarters is in
America they decide to as a group move
to the most remote
uh Air Force Base uh In America which
when they say remote meaning as far as
possible kind of psychologically from
Washington DC so they moved to this
little tiny corner of of Central Alabama
um Montgomery Alabama which even today
Montgomery Alabama is the middle of
nowhere and they want to be they want to
be off by themselves and left a kind of
dream and they have a massive chip on
their shoulder but about that who they
believe to be the the morons running the
army so again you have a and they they
spark this kind of technological
Revolution they dream big and reimagine
what work can be but it's all born of
frustration uh isolation alienation
um rejection rejection I mean it's it's
exactly what you're talking about here
their motives they come across as these
heroic idealists and
these brilliant kind of technological uh
thinkers that's not
that's not how it begins psychologically
they're disgruntled it begins as these
kind of lonely upset disgruntled they're
like I'm sorry we're out of here we're
going to Alabama and they were they
would they would get us only about 10 of
them and they're on this I've been to
this Air Force Base even today it's like
it is literally in the middle of nowhere
and they're just like don't call you
know basically they're like we're hiding
down here don't call us we're like on
the you know as it happens it's such a
marvelous Story the second world war
then breaks out when they're in the
middle of all of this dreaming and
there's no one else who's been thinking
about
air War policy and so all of these
disgruntled guys get whisked out of
Alabama and they occupy all the top
positions in the U.S Air Force at the
beginning of the second world war so by
magic by sheerus chance this group of
Misfits gets plunked into the center of
the American Military machine when
America enters the war in 1942
um so it's like they get a lucky break I
mean if if the second world war never
happened they might still be there like
you know fussing and groaning and
grumbling and which is this other thing
that you know uh thing that I've
observed in I'm sure you've seen the
same thing in doing this in doing this
podcast is the amount of times that
sheer Serendipity unleashes this allows
the innovator to turn their
um disgruntlement and Neurosis into gold
right it's just something random happens
and boom that they they see a window and
they think that's it right that's a
shaft of light that's my light
um but if the window been closed they
could still be disgruntled and running
around
history will never know the history will
never remember that yeah we never look
back and see that that outcome so even
in that case it sounded like that one of
their initial driving motivators was
more like I told you so so going back to
your point about would they be happy
today because they never got that
particular I Told You So moment before
they before they died no they yes they
would have had to live to uh you know a
hundred and hundred years old to get out
to get there I told you so a moment the
question I would have liked to ask them
is
did they did they still have faith at
the time of their death that their
vision would be realized at some point
so there's a whole class of
of uh
innovators who pursue an idea and then
they're just early right and it comes to
fruition afterwards it's a famous case
of a I've forgotten his name but there
was an American
um biochemist who had this idea for how
to fight cancer tumors
um by starving the
cancer tumors grow you know blood feeds
them they have all these blood vessels
that they connect that's how they and
his idea was let's choke the supply of
blood to tumors and we can kill them
that way and it's called angiogenesis
and physical nitrogenesis someone will
correct me anyway he had this idea in
the 60s and he it takes him sort of 30
years to figure out that it works and I
I've often wondered and then he dies but
he gets eat just before he dies he has
this kind of
finally boom he demonstrates that his
life's ambition actually works I've
always wondered had he died like
just before
the moment of would he have died happy
did he die
believing it would someday come his his
notion which is in which is kind of if
you think about it it's
it's intuitively it makes sense if I can
starve the tumor of
of blood of its blood supply I should be
able to choke the tumor that's it's a as
an idea if I just explain that to you
none of us knew anything I'm guessing
about medicine it makes sense right so
he has this idea in 1960 whatever it is
and I think his faith was strong enough
that
had he died before proof of concept
he would still have died happy I think I
don't know though I would love to have
asked him that to have asked about a
hypothetical question
I mean another thing I've learned from
this podcast is generally that the
destination is just a thing that goal
ultimate goal is just a thing that gives
us orientation but we're always on a
journey and I imagine if he had
accomplished that one he would have set
off on another one another Journey so
um
one would assert that because he was
striving towards a meaningful goal I
always say you know when people ask me
what I want for my life now I say if I'm
striving towards the meaning for goals
surrounded by people I love and I feel I
feel somewhat challenged I am happy yeah
and the minute I'm no longer striving so
the goal is complete or I'm not around
people I love and it's not challenging
me it's not outside sort of the outer
limit of my comfort zone Then I then
you're not satisfied so he sounds like
someone that was striving towards a goal
a meaningful goal and that was
challenging him so I imagine
accepted lots of other people began to
believe
that he was wasting his time so he has
that he has he is surrounded by a small
Court of people who believe in him and
presumably a long-suffering wife but
uh the general World in which he's
operating is rolling their eyes by the
end and that's his that's his challenge
that's his challenge so I mean that by
the way as you know incredibly typical
of I mean this this goes into one of my
I'm I'm actually
obsessed with this and this is one of
the reasons I wanted to write about our
Mafia because it is a perfect example of
this idea that it's incredibly simple
but is so often overlooked when we look
at Innovation everyone
including the innovator
radically underestimates how much time
it takes to bring an idea to fruition so
the reason most innovators
do what they do is not that they have a
clear picture
but rather they are they are
massively deluded about their own their
own idea they think it's so obvious and
they should be able to pull it off in
you know five years if they realized it
would take 30 they would never do it
right so they're they're their their
success is based on this illusion
they're by definition delusional
um and every but everyone everyone
involved always thinks that just because
I can describe it clearly and I can make
a case or what I'm doing I should be
able to will it into being overnight
right and I I there's not a single
can you come up with a single
significant Innovation that took less
time than the innovator imagined
no just never happens yeah for so many
reasons yeah I mean legislations that
weren't often the big one yeah that goes
in the way of anything there's a hundred
reasons why everything is takes longer
yeah
um like the the Battle of Lafayette
honestly believed in an idea they
hatched about
completely revising the way war is
fought they thought that you could fight
a war entirely from the air
you would no longer need armies tanks
Navy anything all you would need is
bombers they thought you could fight the
entire second world war with a fleet of
bombers okay they had this idea in 19
let's say 35. they thought they could
pull it off
when the war starts in 1942 they thought
they could pull it off seven years later
we can't even pull it off today we're
getting close
but like it's been they underestimated
how long it would take to bring this
idea to fruition by like basically half
a century right that's the that's what
they're doing but everyone has this
delusion do you know how long my
favorite example is
the the automated teller machine the
cash machine is invented
if I'm not mistaken
in the early 1970s now if the guy who
invented it there's a guy forgot his
name we had him right here right now and
we said when you came up with this idea
and whatever it was in 1973 how long do
you think it would take
to spread this idea throughout the
entire world he would have told you
it'll be all done by 1980. it's a
no-brainer couldn't be easier I'm making
everyone's life easier Banks like
consumers like it it's cash out of a
machine all you got to do is punch in a
code this is the this is not like
computers or I'm not changing anyone's
life everyone wins you know how long it
actually took it took 25 years to make
an ATM machine to make it popular ATM
machines take they're not so they're
invented in the early 70s and they're
not really everywhere until the mid 90s
in the West
why they don't you tell me take a long
time
consumer Behavior has got to change and
they've got to make space for them and
it turns out it turns out it's
complicated consumers took a long time
to my mother is still not taking any
money out of anything
you know so you know she's still I mean
she's 90. she may eventually
but you know it turns out people are the
thing that that guy and all of us didn't
understand is so when it comes to how we
handle how we deal psychologically with
money we are extremely conservative
so I can give you the I can sit you down
and say never have to line up in a bank
again
24-hour access to money and you will
still it'll take a generation for you to
warm up to it a generation yeah that's
it isn't it because the generation is
going to pass because that's too
stubborn to change yeah interesting you
write a lot about this idea of timing
you've written about it in outlines I
believe about the importance of timing
now everything you've said there makes
me feel
maybe a little bit scared as an as an
innovator an entrepreneur because I
might be 50 years out and listen I'm
trying to quench these insecurities now
so I I can't wait 50 years what have you
learned about how we can
um improve our timing or understand if
our timing is good
is that even possible is it possible to
know if our timing is good when it comes
to inventing things creating things
launching a podcast are we too late
people say that to me a lot is this too
late to be starting a podcast you know
yeah
okay cat is timing something we can
control or does it just live in
hindsight I well I do think a lot of
people claim
to understand timing and really what
they're doing is they're they were just
lucky
and they're after the fact
assigning themselves you know a pat on
the back for what
um that is not to say though that there
aren't people who
have a kind of
um at least in flashes have their finger
on the pulse of some kind of marketplace
Steve Jobs comes to mind with
yeah think about Steve Jobs of course is
that he's not he's not a Pioneer in
anything
so he's always late he's late to every
Market that he eventually wins so his
genius was an understanding that being
first is massively overrated he's 10
he's 10 years late on the smartphone
he's
you know every all of the ideas that go
into the first uh the Macintosh computer
are all taken from Xerox Park
he didn't demand any of that stuff he's
so his genius was in understanding that
if you are the first person and you're
probably too early
interesting but also and he understands
as well that
um that in that world of consumer
electronics
um you're better off being the person
who tweaks the idea than the person who
truly innovates in other words what
consumers are interested in is a kind of
mature
experience with their Electronics the
average consumer doesn't really want to
be the one who's pioneering how to
work a kind of
you know stage one laptop or home
computer or they don't want the remember
I don't know if you remember the Palm
Pilot Palm Pilot was an early a way too
early smartphone that was big in the
kind of 90s and it it was for it was
used by a very small number of very
technical technologically focused people
jobs would have looked at that and said
you're never going to win selling a Palm
Pilot it's just not
you need to kind of tweak it two steps
and make it something that an average
person would want to use he was very
commercial in the way that he
um approached uh uh product Innovation
that was his genius so he's in some
sense I think he is exactly what you're
talking about someone who
um who had an uncanny sense of how to
bring something to a mass Market
and when the time was right to do so
yeah although he yes when I when the
time and when the time was right yeah he
did a very good job of never being too
early
the weird concept of being too early but
not one that people are that familiar of
between the ages of um 24 and 34 you
spend 10 years working at The Washington
Post yeah what was what did you you know
that was your 10 000 hours per se what
did that give you that in hindsight you
realize has been so sort of foundational
and important and significant to what
you went on to do
those those are 10 years
well it taught me when I was talking
earlier about that thing about reporting
requiring a kind of fundamental humility
it that was
uh
uh was hammered home
in those years
um
I also learned to write without anxiety
so
you can't be a newspaper reporter
if you have any Neurosis whatsoever
about the act of writing you just have
to you know you have a limited amount of
time the discipline of being forced to
write something every day in a limited
amount of time
for 10 years
um cured me of
a writer's block
ing anxiety you know hey you can't be
that way you're right it's just like
it's like a it's like a boot camp for
writers it just is it um that was
enormously
um useful in
[Music]
um
in kind of freeing me up to spend my
mental energies on
other parts of the writing process right
what about writing generally and the
value that and role that writing has
played on your
self-awareness your personal development
because you know we're living in a
generation I think where writing is
becoming less popular and maybe even
less necessary
maybe that's true maybe it's not
um but I because I do this podcast
because I have other obligations to
write because I have a Instagram
following of millions of people that
expect me to write things every day
I started having to write like it was
the discipline I had to do it at 7 pm I
had to post something and it only in
hindsight I've reflected on how much
that changed my life it helped me
understand the world I was living in
because every day I have to say
something that's true
and in hindsight I go [ __ ] I wish
someone had told me how how much I think
I could Advance my wisdom understand
myself just by
having having some kind of commitment to
publish
every day more from like a personal
perspective you know I'm wondering if
that's if it's if you found a similar
thing I tend to think writers people
that have a something making them right
every day and publish are infinitely
just so much more wise and Incredibly
more self-aware
similar thing with podcasters to be
there
so I think of curiosity as a habit not a
trait
um and I think that too often we think
of it as a trait not a habit by that
distinction I mean
it's not people are not naturally
curious or not not naturally curious
they there are people who have
cultivated the habit of curiosity and
those who have led at life life fallow
what you're describing is an
institutionalized a way of
institutionalizing the habit of
curiosity if you are required to write
something every day
then you are you've put yourself in a
position where you're forced to think
about and look for things to write about
every day that's institutionalizing the
habit of curiosity right I think all
successfully curious people do that in
one form or another put themselves in
situations where they have to come up
with
some new idea or have to are forced to
look for interesting new things or you
know why you know
um anyone who has ambition does this for
many people
the idea you know ambition is very often
rooted in a sense of dissatisfaction
with your current state of knowledge
um or practice what does what does
dissatisfaction do it is another
institutionalization of the habit of
curiosity it forces your your
unhappiness and dissatisfaction with
what you know forces you to go out and
look for a solution to that feeling
right find things that to keep going and
you know instead of stopping get up and
look again and so these are all versions
of the same
um of the same thing so I I sort of
agree with you that there's
writers who have obligations writing
obligations do it's a tremendous
advantage in terms of of
um of uh pushing pushing them to kind of
think freely about things
The Tipping Point
in you wrote that book in 2000 yeah
did that change your life
well it uh it was it it allowed me to
think you could make a living writing
books and it validated my feeling that
the way in which I wanted to write books
had an audience
so I was on I didn't know I had a
particular way that I wanted to write
books but I didn't know whether anyone
else
liked it shared my Approach so that book
made me think oh okay there's a there's
a universe of people out there who
um who are into this kind of thing and
that was that was again freeing you know
at each stage in my career I've been
lucky enough to go through experiences
that allow me to shed various anxieties
The Washington Post sheds anxiety about
writing
Tipping Point sheds anxiety about
whether the kind of writing I want to do
as an audience those are two enormously
freeing things what was the way that you
wanted to write that you were unsure if
the public would receive
I wanted to jump around and go on lots
of digressions
I wanted to use
uh I wanted to make ideas as
make adventure stories around ideas not
about necessarily around people or
narratives
I wanted to kind of ransack the academic
world for really interesting insights
and apply them to kind of everyday
stories I wanted to kind of like
it's an idea of like
um making a book that is a jumble of
different genres right so in the course
of reading a chapter you should
entertain a new idea meet an interesting
person
be have something that you believe
challenged it should be fine to have all
those components in one chapter of a
book
and the next chapter it should be fine
to move on to something completely
different that was what I wanted to do I
wanted to jump around
all the success you've had as a writer
has resulted in you now being doing a
lot of public speaking
one of the things when I was reading
about your your sort of philosophy
towards public speaking that surprised
me was that
um you say you don't try and start a
public talk with a wow
with it with a wow moment I think the
quote was that never starts his talks
with a wow moment or anything to hook
them in but it says tries to draw them
in slowly
and this surprised me because I I've
always thought that the opposite
approach was better as in like when you
walk on stage people are typically on
their phones whatever and you don't have
their attention so trying to get them to
pay attention within the first 10
seconds by saying something
that is somewhat I don't know
provocative was a better approach I was
Keen to hear why you take that stance
the question is what do you want your
audience
and in this sense it's no different from
writing what is the experience you want
your audience to
go through you have them for whatever 45
minutes an hour
and I want them to feel that they have
progressed
I don't necessarily want them to agree
with everything I said or think I'm
wonderful that's not important I want to
be in a different place than they were
at the beginning so to have thought
about something that they hadn't thought
about
to have moved their position on
something a little bit to be emotionally
in a different place so if they started
out one way I want them to be something
somewhere else they started out
distracted I love them to end up being
focused I just want movement right so My
worry is when you start with a bang is
you compromise the movement so
if for example I'm I want them to be
amused their journeyed to be a journey
towards Amusement if the first thing I
do is tell them an incredibly funny joke
the Journey's over
right it's about time so
the central problem of these speeches is
that they've committed
like I say 45 minutes to an hour that's
a long time and everything has to be
about that you have to think about that
time frame you're telling a story Within
a 60-minute window right and they're
going to judge you by how they feel in
the 60th minute not how they feel in the
a minute one
um movies you know the movie that fails
you sit in a two-hour movie and you're
enthralled for the first 90 minutes and
then it falls apart in the end you leave
unhappy you have never I you have never
given a movie recommendation where you
said the following you should totally go
and see that movie the first hour is
amazing now I will warn you the second
hour is terrible yeah you never do that
right yeah you would actually but you
would say oh you should totally see it
it'll be it'll start a little slow and
you'll wonder why you're there but wow
the last hour that you would say I've
described to you this you know from a
logical perspective the same experience
50 good 50 bad but all I've done is if
by by putting the bad first and the good
second I've made it something you
recommend and by reversing it I've made
it something that you would never tell a
friend to do right I actually talk a lot
about to my team about how um people
remember this the peak and the end of an
experience and all the like psychology
tests they do and big tech companies use
this as a way to
um create a more memorable recollection
of any of the sort of customer
experiences and also of the studies
they've done on whether if someone
misses the flight at the start of their
holiday versus if they miss at the end
of the holiday the recollection of the
holidays drastically different exactly
they missed it at the end this [ __ ]
awful holiday there yeah so that makes
sense but my I think my thing is I
wouldn't even have their attention at
the peak of the experience or the story
if I haven't held them at the start with
some kind of promise and we actually see
this with like Mr Beast who's the
biggest YouTuber in the world
much of the reason he says he's
successful and now you 100 million
subscribers fastest growing YouTuber
over the last five years is because he
will at the start of the video and this
is a little bit to do with algorithms he
will tell you the promise he's making
you that you're going to get at the end
so he'll do something in the end like
uh he'll basically create the plot in
the first 10 seconds and go in this
video I buy a million iPhones and then I
text them all at the same time
and you're now waiting till the end to
see the plot realized I guess well he's
he's promising to tell you a story yeah
right so with most stories if you go and
see a
um if you if you pick up a mystery book
mystery story
um it's the same thing by virtue of
being described as a mystery it's making
a promise the promise is I'm going to
you know create some
I'm going to lead you to a dark place
where you don't know where the solution
is and I'm going to give you the
solution so like that yeah he's he's
when you when you when you make the
contract with your audience
and the contract says I'm telling you a
story
you can hold them without you don't have
to why you're not wowing them but you
are you are binding them to you if you
can if you're promising a story then you
deliver on that now he's probably
promised
successfully come through so many times
now that people believe him when he says
I'm going to tell you a story they
believed and they're quite willing to
sit and wait for the for the the you
know the the the the story to be
completed
he actually just say that he says the
second thing is you actually have to
deliver the the punchline of that story
I am so excited to announce our new
sponsor for this podcast and that is
Blue Jeans by Verizon for any of you
that aren't already familiar with blue
jeans they are a video conferencing and
collaboration tool who offer an
immersive communication experience that
drives pretty unparalleled employee and
customer engagement experiences me and
all of my teams across all of my
portfolio companies switched over to
Blue Jeans a couple of months ago and we
have not looked back the best thing for
us has been the totally frictionless
experience no glitching no sound issues
no delays or any of those things that
usually make virtual meetings really
really frustrating we use blue jeans
anywhere on any device at any time and
it's perfect for my small businesses
that just have 10 or 20 people to some
of my bigger businesses that have
hundreds of people I'm a big fan as you
can probably tell so I've been quite
excited for for some time to announce
this partnership and in the coming weeks
I'll explain the features and really why
it's perfect for you if you haven't
considered using or switch over to Blue
Jeans yeah but if you can't wait head
over to bluejeans.com to learn more
honestly it's been one of the real sort
of game changers in my business my
girlfriend came upstairs yesterday when
I was having a shower and she said to me
that she tried the heel protein shake
which lives on my fridge over there and
she said it's amazing low calories you
get your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has about 100 calories in total
while also giving you your 20 grams of
protein if you haven't tried the heel
protein product do give it a try The
Salted Caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me because I'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and I'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where he all fits in my life thank you
heal for making a product that I
actually like The Salted Caramel is my
favorite I've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is the one
are you um are you an emotional person
do you consider yourself to be an
emotional person yeah
does that does that impact your your
writing and your storytelling and your
your
um
authorship
if that's even a word in my podcast very
much so less so in my books
um because audio is so much more
emotional
um so a lot of my religious history
episodes
um many of them are quite emotional
um
and uh they're the ones that I value the
most the ones particularly the ones that
kind of
um this in this season for example
there's two episodes
which one will almost certainly make the
majority of those who listen cry
um
and that's something you can do in audio
and that I think is great accomplishment
real tears not
kind of
um
uh not you know there are some people
who kind of cheat their way to tears
manipulate the way the audience but
well-earned tears
um on that I love that kind of
Storytelling where you can move someone
so deeply that they will respond
emotionally to what you're saying
I saw a quote actually from you that
said um I cry but I don't get mad I
cried but I don't get angry that was it
yeah I don't really get angry much
[Music]
I I don't come from my I don't come from
a family that does anger I don't sort of
see the point it never gets you what you
want it doesn't make sense rationally
it feels terrible emotionally
it just makes everything everyone is
worse off and unhappier after the angry
episode than before so it's like if you
remind me why this is some I mean I if I
have
I try to kind of squelch it whenever I
have an Impulse to do and then I just
find it goes away the impulse when was
the last time you cried
oh I don't know two days ago really
yeah
I tend to cry most often when I'm by
myself I think about something that
causes me to
get emotional
is it typically in your writing or is it
is it you think no I'd be walking down
the street and I would um I will I will
be pursuing a line of thought that will
bring tears to my eyes really
is that what happened two days ago
oh you're walking down the street and oh
are you able to share what that line of
thought was I was thinking about my
father
right uh
I was with my daughter
taking her she's 10 months she's in the
little baby carrier
and I uh
uh my father never met you know died
before she was born and uh
I would dearly have love for him to meet
her
and they have a lot in common I think
although it's hard to tell at 10 months
but um
it seems to my mind they have a lot in
common and I was just reflecting on how
lovely would have been
for them to meet
you're a person of Faith right
so you believe you're Christian
Christianity or yeah that's the
tradition of Griffin yeah yeah same I
grew up in Christianity my we were
always in charge growing up until I was
about 18 years old how has that impacted
the way that you see the world and your
your work and your writing and even that
particular moment because
um being of the Christian faith I
imagine that oh I'm guessing here so
excuse me if the guess is wrong but I
imagine that your belief is that he is
here
and he has meta
uh
yeah
yes I do think that uh
sorry now I'm getting emotional um
yeah I do believe that
why is that um why does that make you so
emotional
um
[Music]
it's varied I don't know sorry
it's very difficult for me to talk with
my father without
uh
his loss was that
just the saddest thing that ever
happened to me
that's right I I would be fine I'm
you know it's it's in many respects a
very beautiful thing what you're saying
in in the sense of his um
the love you clearly have for the man
I I um I always feel particularly moved
when people talk about their fathers and
I've talked about someone's podcast a
lot because I I'm living with this kind
of ongoing regret ongoing
forecast of regret that I'm gonna regret
my father is not at a young age and and
we're not so close and we don't have a
close relationship and I can't seem to
figure out why I don't
do something about it so one of these
stories like that I think it's this
could really Stark reminder to me that
like
parents don't live forever and I'm
living with that illusion that my
parents are going to live forever and
I'm also forecasting the regret based on
speaking to people like you if that
makes sense I'm like it's when people
say what do you regret I think I say I
think I'm going to regret
not um
not having a close relationship with my
parents when they're gone
yeah
well one of the ways
you realize that you're
uh
grief is one of the ways you keep them
alive
[Music]
you know the the thing I feared the most
when my father died was that
uh
was it I would forget him
and
my grief reminds me that I am not and so
it's very it's very valuable
it's um
if I was if I was not
uh
moved by the by thinking about him that
would be a a great tragedy in my mind
but is there a cost to that grief
I think so I mean
I think it's a kind of uh
I said it keeps him alive
um
and
it reminds me
somebody a friend of mine once wrote
uh uh in a book about his own father
that my father he wrote the following
line
my father died 25 years ago
I know him better now than I ever did
back then
um
which I think is one of the most
beautiful lines
true lines
that I've ever
read and I I as time passes
I see that more and more true
of my own father that I I feel I know
him better now than I did when he was
alive
um
and it's hard to explain why that's true
but I uh
but um
and I feel like
if I were to ask my father
about how sad he was about dying
the knowledge that
I know him better now than he did and I
did when he was alive
would make his he would find out that
fact would make his passing easier in
his own mind if that makes sense it's
getting awfully convoluted but I feel
like it's one of the things that makes
death of a loved one less tragic
is that you have an opportunity to get
them to know them better
um
I realize that's hard to it's a very
hard concept to explain it's very
difficult for me to explain when I read
that it just seemed it seemed so
enormously resonant and true
[Music]
um
that something about
the opportunity to kind of reflect on
them
over an extended period of time
and to see them reflected in you know I
mentioned my daughter
to see my father's reflection in her
clarifies my father in my in my mind
you know that specific traits that are
um that are popping up in her
everything from the the size and my
father had an enormous head my daughter
has a truly enormous head and I look at
her head and I think
that's him that's you know like
but uh
we have wandered off
into
all manner of
complex territory yeah it tends to
happen on this in this conversations but
it's really interesting that that
expression because I was thinking about
how I recently had um someone I knew I
knew passed away and the process that
happens in in the wake of their passing
is you first as you would perfectly
saying they were very well in person in
this country they Trend number one and
you you see this outpouring of the
impact they had on others and you go oh
my God it wasn't just me that felt that
way about this person but then their
parents came here and sat on the sofa
and we just compared notes about this
individual and you can start to see as
you kind of describe it there the
patterns and oh yeah no and and it's
almost like the investigation starts
once they're gone and yeah yeah
and so that's why that was that quote
particular quote was so resonant
Timmy um
on the topic of relationships one of the
things that I am in your book blink in
the first chapter you talk about John
just John gottman oh yeah I read about
John gottman completely separately I
read about his when I was trying to read
about relationships and what ruins
relationships I read about this idea of
contempt
ing them yeah I actually when I talked
about my show that went up and down this
country in the show I talk about
professor John gottman I talk about
contempt and how that's this Insidious
little hard to see force in
relationships but you actually got to
meet him what did that teach you about
relationships and
um
and the ones that are going to last in
those that are gonna yeah
kind of obvious but crucially important
point which is a reminder of how
we're social animals and
casting someone out is the Great
um
is the great sin the great injury not
being angry with someone or or anger is
wrong word but
government is clear that anger is not a
predictor of
the expression of anger is not a
predictor of the failure of a
relationship the expression of contempt
is
um
and he makes that crucial distinction
that if I confront you over something
that I'm unhappy about
I am the implicit understanding is I'm
doing this because your our relationship
is of such importance to me that an
injury needs to be addressed right
contempt is where you have given up on
the relationship like ah what's the
point right it doesn't matter
and that idea that it doesn't matter
whatever is worse than I can't believe
you did that
super interesting and it made me kind of
think a lot about
um
would it you know if you're thinking
about building
organization structures relationships
family anything that's that that
is keeps people engaged and happy over
the long term
understanding that distinction is
crucial it is not conflict that drives
people away it is neglect
right and not every encounter has to be
positive to be useful
and you know when I when I thinking
about
the team I work with on my podcast
revisions history for example
we know many of them are much younger
than me and uh there are things I can
teach them and I have a choice do I
bring this up
look guys we screwed up on this this
isn't good or I let it slide my
personality is such that I often would
let things slide otherwise no no that's
wrong and that's I am I am impairing our
relationship by letting I think I'm in
the moment helping things just by
letting my irritation not get the better
of me
no I'm impairing a relationship
when I say to them this isn't good work
and here's how it can be better I am
affirming to them that they are part of
my team
and when I just shrug and say
whatever
then they become Superfluous right I
have truly injured them in that moment
this idea that that's a lot of what
effective management is is
um is implicitly ensuring subordinates
that they belong
that you're you're part of the team even
if that's manifested as in
in terms of
approbation or conflict or what have you
um
uh and that neglect is the
is that neglect is the enemy and in this
shoe in families as well right neglect
is the enemy the thing that you can't we
were talking earlier about about benign
neglect benign's the key word right
considered neglect is fine but when you
turn your back on a child
that's when that's when you do harm
um
and you know none of us were talking
about our parents turning their backs on
us they were watching from far and not
doing anything totally different yeah
totally different it's actually
completely changed my perspective on my
own childhood because you're right I
always thought of them like it being a
form of like bad parenting but it but in
fact I they loved me very much and they
were there at a house and I was safe and
I had a foundation to to flourish in
without that if I wasn't out on the
street you know
yeah
lovelessly which I actually think would
have been even worse than being hungry
just being Loveless uh completely
Loveless and love again even in my child
we weren't maybe an affectionate family
I still don't call my parents by mum and
dad I still call them by their first
names not really but I knew yeah it's
weird it's very strange it just I think
it started as a joke my mum saying she
felt old if we called her mum and she
wanted to be our friends and it was just
a joke that I was born into and never
knew otherwise so I call them by their
first names but I was still well that
they loved me because it was this it was
it was actions it was like trying to you
know being there whenever I was at
danger those kind of things like
um as opposed to smothering
that's really interesting though that
idea and it kind of does it's a bit of a
narrative violation that by giving
feedback and by being honest and
constructive in your feedback you're
actually
showing people that you in even in a
professional sense that you that you
care and that you are together on this
yeah you're not you're yeah that they
are necessary to the process
right it's that feeling of of of of that
they've if they feel they are necessary
then you have you know we've noticed
this I've started this little company on
this Audio company with my friend Jacob
Weisberg called Pushkin produces all of
our podcasts and others um and you know
we've noticed that the people like every
small company we have people who come
and go
and the people who
go are the ones who this is an obvious
observation but it's an interesting one
the people who have tended to leave are
the ones who are the most socially
disconnected from
their organization so who came into the
office the least or who were not were
based in another city and we hired them
largely to do remote work or they have
they don't feel it's very hard to feel
necessary when you're physically
disconnected and
um you know as as we Face the battle
that all organizations are facing now
and getting people back into the office
that this people it's really hard to
explain this core psychological truth
which is
we want you to have a feeling of
belonging and to feel necessary we and
we wanted you to join our team and if
you're not here
it's really hard to do that it's not in
your best interest to work at home I
know it's a hassle to come to the office
but like you know if you work if you're
just sitting in your pajamas in your
bedroom is that the work life you want
to live right don't you want to feel
part of something
I mean it just I I I I'm really getting
very frustrated with the inability of
people in positions of leadership to
explain this effectively to their
employees that
um if we don't feel like we're part of
something important what's the point
it's not you're not just doing this to
get a if it's just a paycheck then
it's like then you what if you reduced
your life to right it has to be
I don't know I I this really is getting
me kind of I was in I was in Los Angeles
a few weeks ago and um
I was
pitching some idea to a studio I went to
two Studios
I won't name them both have these
beautiful gorgeous fancy offices other
sorts you only see in LA right fantastic
you know sun is shining you go into the
parking lot and there are no cars there
and you go into these places where they
normally would have 500 people and there
are four now they say it's because of
covet it's not covered it's just they
they just did everyone's just decided
they want to work at home like this is a
business that is in they are in the
business of forging an emotional
connection through storytelling to an
audience and they cannot even form an
emotional connection to their own
employees right what is going on here
this is nuts you're totally preaching to
the choir by the way because I've had
this I've had this conversation with
with all of my companies in all of my
teams and even the people in this room
now know I've spoken to them about it
I've wrote a letter and I said listen we
believe in um interperson in all
connection the value of it this is why
we've never done this podcast on Zoom
even in the pandemic yeah because I
because part of the reason I do it is
because of this and what I'm not doing
it to publish an episode I'm doing it
because I like to meet someone and
connect with them if you take that away
from it I don't want to do the podcast
and it's the same with my work like we
ran a company who was that when we had
700 employees we were no tourists for
company culture for having this where
the office was like a community center
you know everything happened there and
our employee base again as the BBC wrote
were on average about 21 22 years old
the minute the pandemic comes around for
the first time ever we see people
quitting on mass because Suddenly It's
them doing a to-do list in the boxer
shorts at home and the only upside we're
bringing them in their life the only
sort of remuneration we're giving them
other than you know the work is
interesting whatever is pay it literally
then becomes the pay we're giving versus
the company down the road that are
paying you to set in your box of shorts
and do your to-do list so it became pay
versus pay and to be honest there were
other people that were willing to pay
more so we we saw tons of people leave
and I realized that Central to the value
that we bring to these people's lives is
community and togetherness and
connection so I fully fully believe in
it and I also think that and this is a
controversial thing to say people don't
typically know what's right for them and
and I'm not saying it's just the context
of work I'm saying like look at other
areas of our life where we've sacrificed
Community for productivity or efficiency
where maybe we now sit at home and tap a
glass screen to get our food and then
swipe on a glass screen to get a date
and then click double tap uh photos like
that's probably what you would have
chosen through convenience but then the
cost on happiness which you don't get to
see when you make that transaction
so I I think I said to all my companies
and even some of my foreign companies
like the most important thing for me is
to give you Clarity on who we are then
you can decide where you work yeah and
the problem we've seen over the last
couple of years is spineless virtue
signaling scared CEO specifically that
are in San Francisco like the Facebooks
and the twitters who all had to follow
the same kind of leftist do whatever you
want without realizing that
company culture should be reverse
engineered from your company's mission
and if and when you think about your
company's Mission the thing that will
help you achieve your company's mission
is connectiveness is employee retention
is the sense of community is all the
other things other than just pay these
are all so
um when you think about it from that
perspective thing in fact bringing
people together giving them freedom I
mean don't like they can still have as
much Freedom as they like to decide the
days and what you know they've got to
have freedom because that's also
connected to them fulfilling the mission
but
saying that we are a group of people
that get together because we believe in
that we believe in the value of it yeah
and every time I say this you know
there's a big cohort that yeah amazing
and then
I mean I was at an office this morning
and it's exactly what you've described
they said there's usually 500 people in
there my team were there with me empty
empty completely empty I went to another
office a big ticketing company they
built they'd started building the
construction of this building in central
London during covert they spent what I
believe hundreds of Millions on this
office
completely empty and I go what's going
on again well we're trying to get people
back in we do pizzas on Tuesday
downstairs people still don't come in
why don't you give them Clarity why
don't you say this is who we are because
they're scared you're scared they're
scared to be clear just do whatever you
want decide whatever you want
that's not how teams work name a team
that runs on that basis in sports
do whatever you want
yeah so I think I believe I have a
hypothesis that we're gonna return uh
not not to where we were before because
I think that was somewhat broken as well
but I think we're going to return to a
nice Middle Ground
well freedom and Clarity sadly if an
economic recession will you have that
effect yeah um I mean if when people
start to get worried about their job
um I think that might be easier to get
them uh it's sad that it's going to take
a lot of pain
um but um yeah I suspect that will bring
that will change the culture somewhat
the kind of climate I think it will be
and it Jack is a good example here Jack
was freelance so in the company I
described with the great office culture
whatever Jack used to come in as a
freelancer so he wasn't part of it so he
was one of the people sat at home in his
boxer shorts I'm guessing and he was he
would part of the reason why and this I
don't want to speak for Jack but from
what I understand do correct me if I'm
wrong jack is Jack wanted to move from
there to from being this freelancer to
being full-time in our team was because
he saw that he was missing something
Jack please correct me is that accurate
yes what were you miss what did you well
I'd come to your offices and I'll see
what it was like being part of a team
which I haven't seen before and yeah I
just realized that's what I've been
missing from my work the whole time
and so he was in the freelance sitting
at home and then saw this group of young
people that were all friends and played
football and went out on Fridays and and
thought you know what that's actually
as important as just getting a check you
know so yeah that's my hypothesis I'm
actually going to start using our office
coach as a way to employ people which
kind of bucks the trend that it's gonna
sort of disincentivize people to work
here so yeah oh I mean if it it could
have it could have a really lovely thing
where if you preferentially
select people
based on their desire to work in an
office that's a really wonderful way to
kind of build a nice office culture
right yeah just for the moment you can
just sort of
cream skim all the people who exactly
what a party that would be
those are the people I want to be with
anyways I mean so
yeah another thing that I found um very
curious was this idea that too much
information when making decisions
sometimes can sometimes distort reality
and be unhelpful because
I mean in most of the Pursuits in most
of the businesses I run
the phrases like the more information
the better and even when we're trying to
figure things out we're using looking at
the analytics we're trying to get as
much data as we possibly can to make our
decisions now now in blink you kind of
contest that idea yeah that's sometimes
less information is much
well particularly you know and if these
are unsupported decisions so
um if you're going to be using decision
making tools analytic you know Advanced
analytics and you are confident in
whatever algorithms you're using to kind
of then find but for the
for for sort of much more human decision
making you know we have all kinds of
problems a classic one would be
you know you you want to buy a car and
there are six things you're concerned
about and
you you fall into the default mode of of
weighing all six equally when in fact
you know price is probably five times
more important than color of the car you
know but you have you to make the
mistake of thinking oh I don't want to
buy that one because it's the wrong
shade of green when it's you know Far
and Away that I and that parallels was
something that I I didn't really
understand until I started this company
with I've observed a kind of startup in
operation with this company Pushkin
which is
um
it's really really hard for decision
makers
to focus on more than a handful of
things you the the idea that focused is
a limiting variable in a lot of crucial
decisions it's something that I didn't I
understood it abstractly but now I
understand you simply the reason as a
company you want to pick you know two
lines of business not five it's not that
two lines make more
rational business sense than five but
because you can't focus on
five she can't see him being you only
have a limited amount of your limit of
space in your head right and like so
that idea that we have a limited amount
of space in our head Obama President
Obama used to every morning he would uh
he would have someone lay out his
clothes for him so he didn't have to
think about what clothes he was going to
wear I know on the theory that if you
spend if you devote space to what you're
going to wear that morning you have less
space for other stuff he's absolutely
right it's totally true so we clutter
this idea that cluttering our
decision-making process
with extraneous information in the hopes
that makes us better off in the end is a
Fool's game don't clutter like I said if
we're talking about unsupported decision
making
um if you are you know
IBM sorting through some complex fine or
but I mean for every day kind of stuff
that yeah clear away
prioritize very be very clear about your
priorities
focus on what is crucial that's the way
to be a more efficient
um decision maker in in in the kind of
in the in these immediate unsupported
domains
I really need to do that with my
wardrobe upstairs because I've just I've
got [ __ ] hundreds of I wear two of
the black t-shirts and there's a hundred
in that like in that cupboard but I
could just take the others out and I
could I could really I just thinking
about my life generally How I Live it's
kind of a cluttered clutter experience
which I think my rule is every time I
buy an item of clothing I remove an item
of clothing from my closet so I have
homeostasis
slightly obscure um topic alcohol do you
drink yes because I I read about your
I've seen various sort of opinions you
have on alcohol and I assume that would
mean you you didn't
why were you laughing yeah these are
things I would but which I love to kind
of opine
it's half tongue and cheek wait what so
yes what's your what's your question the
really interesting thing that I was I
was actually reading about just before
you came was about how alcohol is such a
situational thing and how in for many
people it's a depressant if they are sad
alone you can make them more anxious if
they're anxious and then at a football
stadium it can make them jubilant and
feel connected and happy
what's your opinion on alcohol do you
think it's a
a bad thing for society do you think it
should be banned
no I mean I mean like I said I do drink
not to excess but um uh I think of it as
we're stuck with it in a good way I mean
uh we I do think we have we're
relatively Cavalier I mean this is a big
theme in my book talking to strangers
yeah a whole chapter on alcohol and how
a lot of what we talk about is that you
know when we talk about a section the
culture of the problem of sexual assault
particularly among young people it's
really an alcohol problem that's driving
it right it's very very few cases of of
you know accepting violent rape if you
talk about
what we think of as sexual assault um
where one party thinks it's conceptual
and the other party does not that kind
of which are the problematic cases in
many of with young people
someone's always one or both parties are
always drunk in those situations it's
very rare for that not to be the case
and understanding that oh
if we want to tackle really really
serious things like sexual assault we
have to get our hands around
drinking problems first and to
understand that something weird is
happening and drinking has happened in
drinking culture in the last generation
in the west
um which is that the
the fringes have gotten more Extreme
More young people abstain from alcohol
than ever before but at the other end of
the Continuum what it means to be a
heavy drinker today is very different
from what it meant to be a heavy drinker
50 years ago heavy there is more binge
consumption and
um over consumption of alcohol at The
Fringe today than it was in the past
among young people and that's really
problematic
um and trying to understand how to in
reintroduce a culture of
um not necessarily sobriety but of of um
uh of balance in of
um moderation in alcohol consumption is
one of the kind of I think one of the
sensitive Central tasks facing society
today why is that the case why is there
more binge binge drinking on one end we
don't really have a good understanding
of why part of it is I think that
um Norms around uh female drink I talked
about in in talking to strangers Norms
around uh female
alcoholic consumption have changed very
dramatically so
50 years ago if a man and a woman go out
on a date there is zero expectation in
fact they would be
a it would be considered problematic if
the woman drank as much as the man
now there is in many situations
particularly in colleges universities
there is a an expectation that the woman
will match a man drink for drink and
that is
so incredibly problematic for a whole
series of physiological reasons not just
that women not just by the way that
women are tend to be have a lot way a
lot less than men it's not just about
weight it is that women process alcohol
in a fundamentally different way than
men so two a man and a woman who weigh
exactly the same amount can have exactly
the same amount to drink and the woman
will be a lot more inebriated at the end
of that process that is a physiological
fact about men and women so if you have
as a norm that women should match Men
drink for drink you are asking for
trouble
right and our failure to talk frankly
about alcohol abuse among young people I
just think is Criminal it's just like
it's just I feel the same thing about
um in some sense about about cannabis
where
I don't have a problem with people
smoking dope but the idea that we can
have THC levels uh in cannabis that are
north of 25 or 30 percent is insane are
you kidding me it was a one percent a
generation ago and people are smoking
the same amount and it's 25 times as as
I mean it's just like nuts like why do
we suspend the laws of biology when it
comes to uh to mind altering substances
it's just it drives me nuts yes money is
the reason but anyway another time
another time um so we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest leaves a question for the next
guest
um not knowing who they're leaving it
for yeah and so it means that all of our
guests are kind of speaking to each
other I guess this guest has asked the
question
what is one thing you regret not saying
to somebody and why didn't you say it
oh wow
what is one thing I mean the the obvious
answer everyone's going to give is I
didn't say I love you to some loved one
so I'll skip the obvious answer and try
and do something less obvious
um I think it would be I'm this is not a
cop-out
there's a there is a
a genre of
politeness
that I have neglected and that is people
doing everyday things at a lower
the person who being kind Kinder and
more appreciative of the person of the
janitor who sweeps the floor in the
office you work in or the
the woman who cleans your hotel room or
the you know I could make a long list of
the nurse who picks up after you know
you in the hospital or
that
those kinds of people doing thankless
things
I have been I believe I would be I
regret that I have not over the course
of my life life been more obviously
thankful to them
why
why that why did that I mean I agree but
what's made you realize that
now uh
well my mom was in the hospital
she's out now a few weeks ago and uh
I just realized wow like I don't know
it's just something about that
it's obvious but it's not obvious it's
just like
here are people
doing you know very Elemental things
caring for people who are
you know in that moment helpless not
getting paid an awful lot of money
working really really long
shifts just went through an experience
where they were risking their lives by
going to the hospital
for a couple years I mean it's like what
we asked these but we put these people
through
and the idea that we would take them for
granted seems
that I have taken and for granted seems
to me
outrageous
so maybe that's why
welcome thank you so much for being so
generous with your time and thank you
for the conversation
um you're a very special person very
very important thinker for very many
reasons I love the way there's so many
observations I've had for instance
speaking to one of them is that you
really listen which is strange because
often I sit here with podcast guests and
it's the whole like listening to speak
thing but for some reason when I speak
you listen and it sounds like a strange
thing to say but that is really really
surprising because you're very very
smart and maybe that's your dad maybe
that's the because that's what I saw and
it's like that's what you described of
your dad was that humility almost
um so that's incredibly surprising but
then the way that you think and how
considered nuance and your admittance
that you could probably be wrong which
you said many many times I think is also
incredibly refreshing but uh but it's
also why your books are so great and
it's why your podcast is so great it's
why I would recommend everybody to go
and check out the bowl of Mafia because
there's a certain curiosity and wonder
and Beauty to the way that you write and
the reason why you're writing that is
very rare and I hope to one day emulate
in my own writing so thank you for all
of the inspiration and thank you for
doing this
um your podcast you're in season seven
now season seven of revisionist History
yeah and uh that's coming to a close
you've got is it two episodes
yeah season yeah and people can get that
everywhere so Spotify Apple everywhere
yeah
amazing thank you so much Malcolm for
your time thank you generous thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]